Gosh,
if I answer this like completely honest,
like it's just going to be like some
Corny Shit,
you know,
it's going to be like,
um,
I,
I'm sincerely interested,
um,
and how the mind works and in these,
kind of
universal,
timeless curiosities that man has always
had.
Essentially,
why are we here?
What are we doing?
What's this all about?
I'm really kind of depressing
curiosities that,
um,
for me have been answered,
through,
um,
exploring psychedelics.
So,
and you know,
you can decide if you want to edit all
this however it went.
But I grow my own mushrooms and develop
relationships with a lot of different
plants in order to find some kind of
insight and answers
to those curiosities about why we're
here and what's this all about.
And I don't do drugs recreationally at
all and I don't,
you know,
just trip out and enjoy the world here.
What I do is go in to my own mind as
deeply as possible to find
answers and then come back
and I know what to do.
And I know that sounds incredibly corny,
but that's the answer.
Um,
and that's why,
um,
for instance,
I'm trying to create,
work that up.
Yeah.
That reflects that psychedelic
experience through kind of the fractal
based,
um,
construction of the picture plane.
And,
um,
one of the things I've learned is to,
create my own world and share that
with as many people as possible,
you know,
understand what makes me unique and then
share that and inspire others.
So maybe answer is inspired,
you know,
the desire to inspire others inspires,
inspires me.
Yeah.
You know,
the,
the aesthetics are almost kind of the,
uh,
you know,
a,
a superficial reflection of the
experience or experiences.
Um,
they are,
to some degree that aesthetic Trojan
horse,
um,
you know,
the kind of psychedelic colors and
compositions.
Um,
I,
um,
I think are,
are,
are beautiful,
but that's not the real message.
That's not the real content.
That's just the,
the form,
you know,
that's just the,
the,
the beauty that brings you in,
I think.
Yeah.